[Música]
economía aquí en directo América me
acompaña en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de los resultados de las bolsas
en Estados o de la bolsa en Estados
Unidos de las empresas de Gran
capitalización Así que vamos a empezar
con alfabet que es la empresa matriz de
Google que reportó su ritmo de
crecimiento más lento desde la pandemia
del covid 19 alfabeto obtuvo ingresos
por 69,100 millones de dólares en el
trimestre de Julio a septiembre lo que
supone Un aumento del 6% respecto al
mismo periodo del año anterior pero es
la primera vez que los ingresos
trimestrales interanuales de alphabet
aumentaron menos del 10% desde el
período abril junio precisamente del año
2020 los ingresos por publicidad
ascendieron a 54 mil millones de dólares
un 2% más que en el mismo periodo del
año anterior la empresa ganó 13,900
millones de dólares eso Es
aproximadamente 1,06 dólares por acción
lo que supone un comienzo del 27%
respecto al mismo periodo del año
anterior por acción ya hablemos ahora
del gigante tecnológico Microsoft que
presentó resultados como les fue Bueno
esta empresa también reportó una caída
del 14% de los beneficios del trimestre
Julio septiembre en comparación con el
período del año anterior el beneficio
neto trimestral de la empresa fue de
17.600 millones de dólares o 2,35
dólares por acción lo que superó
levemente las expectativas de Wall
streets los ingresos fueron de 50 mil
100 millones de dólares en el trimestre
un 11% más que el año pasado superando
también las expectativas de los
analistas el negocio de Microsoft fue
afectado por el aumento de los precios
también porque muchos consumidores
compraron nuevos dispositivos durante la
pandemia del covid 19 lo que hizo caer
la demanda en este trimestre los envíos
mundiales de ordenadores personales
cayeron casi un 20% en el trimestre con
respecto al mismo periodo el año
anterior y otro de Los afectados
Santiago es en la inversión publicitaria
fue Spotify la empresa dijo que los
márgenes de beneficio del tercer
trimestre se vieron reducidos por el
lento crecimiento de la publicidad
avivando el impacto de una recesión
económica en la publicidad digital
Spotify cuyas acciones han caído
58,5% este año dijo que los márgenes del
tercer trimestre fueron menores de lo
que había esperado pese a esto el número
de usuarios activos mensuales ascendió a
456 millones en el tercer trimestre eso
Es aproximadamente 23 millones de
usuarios más en sólo tres meses Jorge
seguimos hablando de grandes
transacciones porque elon musk anunció
que más tardar el viernes completaría la
compra de Twitter así le dijo a sus
inversores bueno según una fuente
cercana a esta negociación los
principales inversores ya recibieron la
documentación necesaria para cerrar esta
compra secoya capital vainas la
autoridad de inversión de Qatar y otros
fueron notificados para continuar este
compromiso de financiación de parte de
los abogados de elon Moss según
bloomberg los bancos que se
comprometieron a financiar la compra ya
redactaron el acuerdo final de
financiación de esta deuda y están en
proceso de firmar los documentos
necesarios las acciones de Twitter se
dispararon al conocerse la noticia y
cotizaban también con una subida del 3%
a
52,95 dólares más cerca del precio de la
oferta de Moss que fue de
54,2,20 dólares por acción mencionábamos
en el informativo los nombramientos
hechos por Richie song para su gabinete
esto que reacciones provocó en los
mercados y en la economía británica
bueno su ex que se convirtió en el
tercer Primer Ministro de Reino Unido en
lo que va de este año el Primer Ministro
prometió unir al país con acciones y
criticó el presupuesto de La saliente
listrof que causó conmoción en los
mercados y la caída de la libra
esterlina Pero esto opinaban en Londres
los sobre su llegada al poder escuchamos
va a tener un inicio muy ocupado Muchas
cosas que resolver el tema de la
economía es lo principal creo que tiene
un trabajo muy difícil tiene dos años
para darle la vuelta No creo que pueda
hacerlo creo que hizo un poco de lío con
la economía va a argumentar de manera
diferente
creo que como canciller durante la
pandemia trabajó muy bien con Boris
Johnson y ahora llega a ser Primer
Ministro que es el siguiente paso y
estamos seguros de que va a tener mucho
éxito
le hablamos ahora de Colombia porque el
presidente de ese país Gustavo Petro se
dio algunos puntos de la Reforma
tributaria para poder destrabar su
aprobación el gobierno declarado y que
no se grabará en las pensiones altas y
que la sobretasa al petróleo y del
Carbón se aplicará con con base a los
precios internacionales de los
hidrocarburos el anuncio estuvo a cargo
del mismo presidente Gustavo Petro luego
de reunirse los componentes de la
Reforma tributaria de los partidos de
gobierno para analizar los aspectos más
criticados de esta iniciativa incluso
sus aliados han criticado el proyecto de
reforma tributaria muchos de cuyos
artículos también son cuestionados por
empresarios gremios y otros sectores que
consideren que será perjudicial para la
economía el impuesto a las pensiones más
altas es considerado como por algunos
como inconstitucional al considerarlo un
derecho adquirido y no una fuente de
renta se convirtió en uno de los puntos
más polémicos de esta reforma el
artículo buscaba grabar las pensiones
superiores a los dos mil dólares
mensuales la medida también buscaba
generar equidad en el sistema tributario
y fue una de las banderas durante la
campaña de Petro pero hoy fue descartada
por el mismo presidente Muchas gracias a
Jorge por esta actualización de las
noticias del mundo de la economía a
continuación el debate aquí en directo
América
[Música]